you know I like pieces like John Wick in
the sense that you know there's
the action of it but there's also the
emotion the world that's created for me
it's not just the action but it's also
the story and we do still see him you
know missing grieving you know and the
love that he's lost he just wants to be
left alone in the first five minutes you
kill a guy with a book well you know
you've been in some libraries where you
want to kill something but uh for love
and I think John Wick has a different
flavor I don't know it feels authentic
in a way you know what I mean it still
has that independent movie Spirit true
and they're fun and I feel like John
Wick gives the audience a hug